hello everyone and welcome to round 13
of the 2018 world wits championship we
have again between Magnus Carlsen
onigiri two of the lederhosen is the
sole leader with with Artemia vladislav
after drawing that game in in round 12
but Giri also trying to catch up and
Giri has the black pieces in this
matchup and we also said that it's very
interesting as two of them often have
their little bras brawls on Twitter so
definitely our game to check out yeah so
without further ado it's a pls game
we're not going to overanalyze it but we
are definitely going to enjoy it
Carlson is the defending 2017 world with
champion and he opens with c4 we have E
5 by Giri nice to see 3 and the knight
to f6 the English opening on the board
the two Knights variation Knight f3
Knight to c6 we go into the four Knights
variation of the English efore and now
Bishop to c5 Giri allows cross in a neat
trick that kind of forces matters Knight
captures on e5 and okay Knight captures
on e5 and we have d4 now attacking the
two pieces of course you want to win at
least one of the pieces back and here
Gary goes for Bishop to b4 it's a known
move this is nothing new being played D
captures on e5 Knight captures on e4 now
with the threat of capturing the knight
on c3 and we have Queen to f3 forcing
the Knights to capture but also guarding
the c3 square
Knight captures on c3 be captures on c3
attacking the bishop and here Gary goes
back to e7 so the bishop can help out
with the defense but already this is
move 10 and we have Queen to g3 and now
it's very I mean you have these messed
up pawns on the entire board for cousin
but the response are intact but also he
still hasn't started developing anything
everything is completely undeveloped
well Carson is free to develop any any
way he wants and already he's attacking
the g7 pawn and you can't castle if you
can so you're just gonna get the bishop
to h6 threatening checkmate you cannot
defend it as the pawn covers f6 you're
gonna have to give up the exchange here
and we'll be better for the rest of the
game so Gary tries this
here sorry g6 here now kind of preparing
to castle but Carson of course prevents
it with Bishop to h6 and here Gary
played the d6 I'm very surprised that he
didn't try Bishop to Bishop to f8 here
and d6 is a move that was played in a
there were four other other games that I
found in this exact same position three
of them were won by white one of them
ended in a draw but black can definitely
go for some sort of a trying of a
threefold repetition after Bishop g5
simply Bishop to e7 Bishop h6 Bishop f8
Bishop g5 and the white it doesn't have
a better mood than Bishop 286 I think I
think Sharon mama dr of drew a similar
game with the white pieces in some
tournament and then everyone was like
all what are you doing not this exact
same position but it was similar but
okay Gary wants to play d6 Bishop 3 -
Carson prepares the castle Bishop to e6
gear is not preparing Queen d7 and
queenside castle as well he's not
castling kingside
rook to d1 and now comes Queen to d7 now
the path is cleared he captures on d6
pawn captures on d6
and now we have castles queenside castle
and the cross and brings back the bishop
as there is no point for the ship to be
covering this diagonal anymore you are
attacking the a7 phone so you can either
defend it with the King but then the
King goes into this diagonal where the
queen is so Gary decides to activate the
Queen and also defend the a 7-point
Queen to f3
personal attacks the b7 point he's
preparing rook to be one and he retracts
the trade of Queens Carlsen of course it
doesn't want to trade material as his
pawn structure is all messed up Queen to
f4 now keeping everything on the board
the Queen cannot be attacked for the
moment and we have b6 here
the a7 pawn is no longer attacked but
the b6 pawn now becomes a target and
Carlsen starts attacking it now we have
a four and now you could grab the pawn
with with your queen but then rook to e1
simply takes a hold of the semi open a
file
rook to d7 trying to activate this rook
as a defensive piece but then you get
then you get some Queeny Queeny for
quindi for ideas as the rook on h8 is on
defended in the black will one attends
to this at some point as well a five
Crossin wants to bust open the queenside
be captures on a5 and now comes work to
be one taking or taking a hold of the
only open file on the board that is the
B file rook to c7 by giri hoping to
capture on c4 and here Carlsen plate c5
you don't want to play something like
bishop to have three too soon and then
black gets to capture this c4 point
which would be great for black what
would still be better but the black is
doing something but after this rook to
c7 cousin plate c5 opening up the
fourth-ranked but also now the Queen
cannot capture you can only capture with
the pawn and then you also open up this
diagonal this diagonal and but other
than this c5 move there was a an even
even greater idea so it's a really cool
move I know it's a blitz game we're not
gonna overanalyze anything but feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
the crazy move for those of you who were
able to do it from graduations you are
an excellent calculator over the entire
board and for those who enjoy Bishop
captures an a7
of course the threat is rook to b8 which
would win the rook and if you capture
the rook the bishop then we have this
idea that the rook on h8 is undefended
Queen d4 attacks both of the rocks that
are undefended white is winning here but
okay Causton went for c5 also an
excellent move D captures on c5 and now
cousin went ashore to f3 attacking the
Queen are also an interesting movies
Bishop to b5 which wins the game on the
spot you will either win the Queen
there's nothing not much you can do
about this if you try this then you get
to this check and then rook picks up the
Queen rook picks up the Queen I figure
all the way back with the Queen didn't
get Bishop to a sex check and then
you're just king d8 Queen e5 attacking
the rook after the rook moves the rook
fd1 check now the King has to move the
rook and c7 is unprotected Queen
captures rook and it's all over but okay
after D captures on c5 Bishop to f3
attacking Geary's Queen Queen to d6
offering a queen trait and now Queen
to e4 and here I'll move 24 get replayed
Luke to d8 but it was far too late as
his time ran out before he could hit the
clock but it wouldn't matter it's also a
very interesting position for you to
solve so again feel free to pause the
video here and try to find what wins
here for white I'll give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent rook sacrificer and for those
of you just wanna enjoy rook to b8 check
that deadly move as if you capture it
then Quinn to a check is checkmate and
if you don't capture if you try to run
away King to the 7 then of course Queen
to a4 check not allowing the King to
escape via a 8 you have to block this of
course you don't want to block with the
Queen as the bishop is controlling c6
but after roadblocks bunch of captures
you get Queen captures and now rook to
b7
forced the King eater to go back and
then Queen captures Queen or you will
protect the Queen but then you get Queen
f4 check King d5 and c4 will be a very
nice checkmate so yeah after this rook
to d8 Gary's time ran out but it's also
a completely winning position for steam
1812 would best defense so yeah an
excellent the game by by Carlsen with
the white pieces against onigiri and
Peter like also said that it's very
weird that give you a loud Crossin to go
for these types of structures as Carson
was definitely prepared for them as
there were chances that Caruana would go
for something like this during the World
Chess Championship match oh but yeah
it's blitz anything can happen and it's
always enjoyable so yeah I would like to
thank Hamish Mahajan and Wolfgang
Erlanger for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon with
some more games from the 2018 world
blitz championship
thank you all and I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
Sunday